we got uh Cowboy what's up cowboy
I uh
she's on a smear campaign and I don't
really know how to deal with it
the a girl from the group is on a smear
campaign or is it somebody that you're
dating oh this is an X
and what's happening what is she doing
uh just
running my name through the mud uh false
allegations you know the story uh
divorce how it goes assassination of
your character
I broke my neck I was on the episode 80.
told you about that uh the bad tick bite
haha uh
so many friends have gone with her or uh
because we were all a group of friends
and they you you know the title of it
was they're not your friends well
people I've known for 15 20 years I
thought were very near and dear to me
have just ghosted me and nope what is
she telling them
oh you know the typical narcissistic
abusive uh
you weren't in the home so you didn't
know
those kind of things hmm and these guys
are no longer talking to you as a result
of her storytelling
for sure and they were friends of yours
too
yes sir uh I raced boats in a very
private Community uh we run shallow
rivers yeah
I got 600 horse in my boat plus I hit it
with a 300 shot of nitrous uh
very tight-knit group of people
um the place we camped at we had 20
campers
everybody was a couple we were all
friends
two of the
gentlemen in that group have reached out
hey it's been a year how you doing
haven't heard from you and I basically
self-isolated I'm trying to re-uh
reassert my life and uh
you know the broken neck thing that's a
big thing uh the tick bite was a big
thing so I'm I'm trying to realign my
life with higher standards and and
higher quality people but when they're
the highest quality people in your town
you start to think maybe I should move
towns where do you live
uh about an hour south of St Louis
Missouri
okay
um look man at the end of the day
you've formed this like Vortex of like
friendships when you travel in circles
you know either with your wife or with
your girlfriend for a while and they
start talking to wives and girlfriends
and Friends become friends of those
sorts of things and at the end of the
day like if me and my gal broke up and
friends that we had that we traveled in
circles was let's say you know that's
the rally group or something like that
and then they stop talking to me or they
didn't want to hang out anymore if I
text them and say Hey you know let's go
get a coffee or let's go to this place
and do something and they weren't
responsive or they made up excuses
who cares you know they've done you a
favor you know do you have to do you
have to get up and explain yourself to
them do you have to ask them you know
why are you listening to my crazy ex
because if they're because if they're
that gullible and they're that
persuadable do you really want them as
friends
no and I've realized that like uh
the sincerity of people is genuinely 90
not as much as you're gonna give
and you know like I said at the start of
the show like you will be betrayed by
women in your life and you will be
betrayed by friends these are the two
most difficult areas that you have to
contend with when you're a man is that
people are gonna [__] you over your
friends will screw you over and women
will screw you over and I'll be honest
with you they hurt just as much
right you know like if you ego invest
into a friendship with a guy and you
travel and you do things together and
you build bikes together and you you
race together and you do all this sort
of stuff and then all of a sudden they
just turn around and they backstab you
it hurts just as much as if a chick goes
and bangs another guy it's another it's
just another form of betrayal
right so
when somebody shows you who who they are
what's the old saying believe them right
you know so how do you develop a true
network of friends I mean dude I was in
the Marine Corps that's Blood Brothers
like you can't yeah so what happened to
all those guys that you you know came up
with
uh time drifts you apart yeah location
you don't hang out as much I mean I
could still call them and they'd still
be there for me but it's not a it's not
a weekly it's not a monthly it's not a
daily need it's a once every two three
years yeah uh those were the guys that I
hung out with every single weekend you
know make it more frequent you know make
it a reason for you guys to get together
like uh look I've got some local friends
but I've also got guys in my community
like I've talked about my one percent
Community for years now
um it started out as like a patreon tier
basically and then I pulled it off that
Plum platform and off Facebook because I
don't like the way that it was going so
I have a private community and if you
guys you know see my Social Media stuff
like if I'm if I'm on Instagram you'll
see me traveling to places like Colorado
skiing with a lot of these guys or a
couple weeks ago we just went hunting
you know or I'll travel down to the
Caribbean right you know sort of thing
so it's like there's opportunities to
network with other people that don't
live in City and I don't mind traveling
for that I'm not a guy that really likes
to travel to be honest with you like I'm
I'm not down with airports and air
travel it's a real pain in the ass I
kind of hate it at this stage I did just
join the 10 community and I did do the
School of Entrepreneurship okay and I'm
loving them both good so yeah so that's
a good starting area like that's a
staging ground right but like most of
the like higher level meetups and
conversations like that like the hunting
stuff was only extended to guys in the
one percent community that are top-tier
generals that have been around for a
while and prove themselves so you have
to get involved you have to have
conversations hop into the zoom calls
hey you know this is going on what's
going on somebody asked a question I
have experience with that let me see
what I can do to be useful there sort of
thing you see what I'm saying right like
you get out of it what you put into it
I Network a lot I've been hog hunting uh
uh Circle K uh hog hunting ranch in
Texas uh is a good friend of ours uh
I love hunting I love killing [__] and
stuffing it and putting it on the wall
but
those weren't the guys that I did that
stuff with those were the guys that I
hung out
uh weekend soccer games putting the kids
together and all of that has been
divided uh
which is
it's a very hard pill to swallow
Reach Out make the effort if it's not
reciprocated or if they ghost you or
they
I heard your wife said this that or the
other thing or you know you hear it from
someone else it's just like why even
bother with them like
there's one thing that I've learned
about friendships as I've gotten older
because I've because I've seen this over
and over again Cowboy you know I've seen
this in my 20s and my 30s I've even seen
it in my 40s now dealing with guys in a
mano swap right like you know you think
people are your friends and they've got
your back when you help them out when
you lift them up when you answer their
questions when you uh protect them when
other people are trying to attack them
sort of thing but they don't really like
you're going to get that in life it's
it's it's always going to exist you just
have to leave these people behind
and you don't have to hate them you
don't have to ruin their lives you don't
have to do anything malicious like some
of these asshats do just
put some distance that's all it is and
you and you move on
um you know you have these epochs you
have these chapters in your life right
like what you're doing now is not what
you were doing in your 30s or even in
your 20s or your teens and that's okay
like a lot of people think that you make
friends for lives like people put so
much emphasis in high school friendships
you know in the teen years and even in
the 20s
and I'll be honest with you there's
probably one guy that I have in my phone
right now if I were to call him he'd
probably answer from high school the
rest of them I don't even talk to
right and that's okay that's okay you
just leave those friendships behind you
just leave them behind
no I I get it I went to three different
high schools I made many many friends
and I
I take that back I made many of
acquaintances that's that's exactly it
that's the distinguishing difference
right yeah because I mean your best
friends
you can walk up to their front door at
two o'clock in the morning with a shovel
in your hand and say I got a problem
it's in my trunk I need help
and his answer will be like we taking
your car or mine
doesn't ask you what the problem is it's
a good friend but those are doesn't ask
me what the help is right like those are
the kind of guys that have your back
it's the kind of guys that will talk
[__] to your face they'll make fun of
your car they'll make fun of your boat
they'll say your motorcycle is too
feminine nice bike does it come in men's
or something like that but they'll
always protect you behind your back so
when your ex-wife or your ex-girl talks
[__] about you they don't want to hear
it I know Cowboy who's my boy I trust
him I'm not interested in hearing your
narcissistic rants about or whatever it
happens to be so when they pick a side
like that and they've shown you who they
are then do yourself a favor and just
don't even bother them you know if you
want companionship just get a dog I
always tell guys this you know they want
they want a woman as a companion they
want to a best friend that's 18 years of
marriage man that's gonna be your best
friend 20 years together I will tell you
there is no such thing as your woman is
your best friend your best friend isn't
even your best friend because if he
could he would bang your old lady
just because that's the way it works
it's a very uncomfortable and
unfortunate fact and truth yes it is I
agree
I uh I appreciate talking to you sir I
appreciate all you do and uh hopefully
you can help some more men uh get better
at life hop in the zoom call tomorrow
we're on at uh three for the School of
Entrepreneurship I will do sir we'll
talk some more then all right man thank
you see you buddy I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out